[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this morning on the dish chefs scott
tassinelli and angie rito their
restaurant don angie won a prestigious
michelin star they've both been
nominated for the james beard award and
the new york times called their
restaurant the future of red sauce
italian cooking the two recently
published their first cookbook fittingly
called italian american i met up with
them at their acclaimed venue in
manhattan's west village to talk about
food family and their special taste for
innovation
we'll take the the sweet fennel sausage
one pound for chefs angie rito and scott
tassinelli their labor of love starts
with hand-picked ingredients today's
from a local italian deli we love to use
that sausage specifically actually as
the base of our bolognese sauce so this
will be this will be perfect
back at their restaurant don angie that
personal touch has helped elevate
italian-american food pick up calamari
to a kind of new age italian cuisine
this is our italian sausage bolognese
sauce so in trying to take a dish
and make it your own how much fun how
much enjoyment do you get from that
i mean a lot that's what that's what
the whole donation menu really is i
think new takes on classic type dishes
familiar flavors but like surprising i
think that was the only way to make this
restaurant kind of stand out i was lucky
enough to get a sneak peek at where the
magic happens we use a lot of cheese at
the restaurant i'm just letting you know
like i really like cheese scott gave me
a crash course in preparing one of don
angie's signature dishes their pinwheel
lasagna so you're going to kind of come
in and you're going to tuck it under
like this and then you're going to roll
it really
just go for it just roll it really fast
like a burrito unlike the traditional
version the pasta is pre-sliced then
baked on its side invigorating the old
standard we kind of have an advantage
because we're two chefs running a
restaurant where if it's just one chef
right they don't have the other person
with the same creative knowledge to kind
of help them
yeah it's just always it's always a
conversation but scott and angie aren't
just partners in business they're also
partners in life
husband and wife and recent first-time
parents they met while working at the
same new york city restaurant love at
first sight or friendship at first
second i think it was love at first
sight on my part
i mean i love angie they say love
blossomed while traveling and played out
across dinner tables throughout
manhattan lasagna i would take her
around to all different restaurants and
then we started going to italian
american restaurants together like red
sauce old school red sauce restaurants
yeah it's just everything about it that
you know the nostalgia of it and so
that's where we kind of really
our love like flourished i think both
have red sauce running through their
veins angie grew up in cleveland working
in her grandfather's italian bakery and
specialty store and learning traditional
recipes from her neapolitan grandmother
food was like the centerpiece of every
family gathering always a lot of it my
grandmothers on both sides would just
make you know copious amounts of food
for everyone like way too much that
anyone could ever consume but that's
just the way it was and food was love
yes of course scott says food was also
love for him as a kid in new jersey his
grandparents like angie's also italian
american and avid cooks along with his
mom
but for scott cooking as a career only
came after a decade in ad sales i kept
thinking like i don't want to do this
for another year let alone like another
30 years so i've always loved cooking i
always wanted to try it so i went to
culinary school and took some classes
and fell in love with it and then just
kind of went from there
at don angie the duo has combined their
passion for food
and for family the inspiration has
always been yes the food that we grew up
eating that we're so passionate about
but we also kind of want to do stuff
that's surprising and unique to people
like how do we kind of make stuff that's
warm and comforting and soulful but kind
of put some little spins here and there
so it's so it's fun for people yeah
like this familiar favorite spaghetti
and meatballs but served in a frittata
i'm with you on spaghetti and meatball
fruit
it's so simple and mortadella spiedini
topped with pickled garlic salsa verde
there's also the spicy baked clams
francesco we call them that because they
have a little kick from frank's red hot
in there a local pizza joint in angie's
hometown inspired their italian
italian-american wedge salad topped with
creamy herb dressing and pepperoni and
for dessert how about pinole cookies
with rosemary and lemon or
vietnamese coffee tiramisu
vietnamese coffee is really delicious
it's usually made with a chicory based
coffee and then a lot of sweetened
condensed milk so we make a
a cream filling that has
sweetened condensed milk in it and then
a custard with a sweetened condensed
milk in it as well that's phenomenal
phenomenal
and thanks to their new cookbook there
is no reservation required to get a
taste of some of don angie's most
popular offerings why did you want to do
a cookbook
we just wanted to
to share our cuisine i guess with like a
broader audience and and bring our
cuisine into people's homes we really
set out with this book to make something
that was approachable for home cooks we
want people to get their hands dirty and
and use it and cook get red sauce all
over and they've been doing it which is
insane like every day multiple times a
day we get like notifications on
instagram people posting pictures of the
stuff they make out of the book and it
you know it's really it's really
heartwarming it's really cool
no matter the setting it's family
traditions carried on one dish at a time
people have a great time here and a
great experience and they love the food
and that's all i could ask for i have to
pinch myself sometimes because it's very
special that we can
sort of like contribute to people's
lives and make them happy making them
feel
welcome and comfortable and having a
wonderful meal here or or sharing some
of our recipes with them at home yeah i
think it's yeah it's a great feeling
mangia mangia
lasagna for you and an apparel spritz
and what's really cool about i mean
their restaurant is so inviting and
welcoming but also that cookbook angie's
more like the self-taught chef because
she grew up in all of this and scott the
classically trained and so these recipes
have this mix for everyone oh my god and
it's really an amazing way to bring a
little that taste at home the cheese
right right leave it no this is
tremendous i want that
spaghetti and meatball oh frittata was
so so good i mean think about it you
have spaghetti meatballs leftover in the
fridge
or put it in a frittata why not
michelle's writing this all down don and
john angie good luck getting a
reservation there
there's my nose buff to get some
reservations i think we know people
they're a wonderful couple and they
bring joy to their food and you can
taste it ah i love it